starwars I got to say I brought that up
earlier you need to be what electrified
people Star Wars hard to target our
Hargett oh so many laughs flying around
but the point is Star Wars that's the
big deal how was that Star Wars that was
I think the gear right now is Star Wars
yeah I think that noise came from yeah
it's coming from the rafters you know I
was
I was afraid of this theory wops up
there Andy oh that's terrible i you know
i hear they carry a lot of disease yeah
they're awful we've had this problem
before yeah they say if you see one he
walk there are usually hundreds more
you're not seeing charlie can get in
here please
yeah okay that's Charlie hey there mr.
O'Brien you know we took a look up there
and you've got a major yacht infestation
we're finding a ton of you walk dropping
oh that's awful those things stain they
never come out awful
I've got my guys up there ready to smoke
them out just waiting for you to give
the go-ahead okay yeah well you know a
gentleman I'm sorry but we have
something about the ewoks we have to do
right now yeah all right all right boys
let er rip and play that music I gave
you at a drawn-out
[Music]
follow me
[Music]
99
that's right they're dead
thanks a lot character no problem hey be
sure to view us review us on Yelp yep
sure was worth holding for that line
[Applause]